[Music]
geospatial insights can help your
organization realize a more prosperous
and sustainable future want to see how
let's take a look at google earth engine
a powerful platform that makes
uncovering these valuable insights
possible
earth engine was launched over a decade
ago as a geospatial analytics platform
that takes planet scale data and i mean
that literally and figuratively and
couples it with the computing power of
google's infrastructure
researchers scientists and developers
alike have been driving impact across
sectors by detecting and quantifying
changes mapping global trends and more
consider a research team who used earth
engine to build an innovative monitoring
and alerting tool to protect against
illegal logging so how might that relate
to your work let's dig in
we're excited to now provide limited
commercial availability of earth engine
so data and geospatial professionals
like you can accelerate impact within
your own business and augment the
impact-driven work being done every day
by the vibrant community of earth engine
users
here are three things for you to put in
your mental map for how earth engine can
help you on your team the data catalog
development flexibility and common
business drivers
first the data
living up to google's mission that is to
organize the world's information and
make it more accessible and useful
we've cataloged over 50 petabytes of
analysis ready data about the earth's
present past and future
this includes climate and weather data
imagery from satellite platforms such as
landsat sentinel and modis and other
geophysical data like terrain and land
cover maps in both raster and vector
formats
time series data stretches back over 40
years in some cases
and on the other hand of the clock there
are many real-time data sets too
the increasing volume of satellite
launches with ever more sophisticated
sensors is helping fuel an explosion of
fresh high frequency earth observation
data as well
so that means more and more data
becoming available
along with the need for platforms to be
able to ingest store and process them
efficiently
fortunately this is something google and
earth engine are equipped to handle at
scale
what that means is that users like you
get to focus on just the fun stuff
geospatial analytics and data science
accessing the data in earth engine is as
simple as a few lines of code so bring
your hypotheses know the extent of your
analysis and time horizon and you're
ready to go
second consider the flexibility of the
development environment
earth engine has a computational engine
that can handle the complexity and
global scale that thousands of phds
developers and data scientists throw at
it every day
there are several options for you to
access and work with the data that takes
advantage of that computing power
you can connect to the earth engine
service through one of its apis
client libraries for javascript and
python translate complex geospatial
analyses into earth engine requests
or connect directly to earth engine
servers using the rest api
earth engine also provides an
interactive environment with an online
code editor ideal for prototyping and
iteration
more comfortable in python earth engine
also works in python notebooks like
colab
you can even run inference directly from
satellite images using cloud ai platform
from earth engine and the results are
returned to you as an image or set of
features right in earth engine that's
cool right
when you're ready to go global scale you
can take advantage of earth engine's
batch mode to process petabytes of data
within a massively parallelized
environment
with zero configuration or server
management
to create interactive experiences of
your analyses that can be securely
shared with your users you can use earth
engine apps with its library of ui
components and hosted platform
finally there are a handful of common
business drivers that you or maybe
someone else in your organization are
thinking about already
vexing questions like how resilient is
my business to effects from climate
change
how or is my business compounding
economic and societal issues around
deforestation or pollution
or what else can i do to support our esg
reporting initiatives
there are common themes we see across
commercial applications
one for example is using climate data to
understand risk or impacts to physical
assets like infrastructure or real
estate holdings across disparate
geographies
beyond assessing risk there are many
other use cases to spark your creativity
to
okay we've covered a lot about earth
engine and there's so much more for you
to check out head on over to our website
where you can explore the data catalog
read through a few case studies as
inspiration and register your team's
interest in accessing earth engine
during preview
we can't wait to hear about the
initiatives you all will be driving and
the combined impact we can make together
with google earth engine for creating
prosperity resilience and sustainability
for your organization
[Music]
you